foreign
Snapchat reports that more than 5
billion Snaps are generated daily and
more than 100 billion messages are sent
on WhatsApp deal do you ever wonder if
storing this data in local storage is
possible the answer is clearly no
according to the projections by 2025
over 100 zettabytes of data will be
stored in the cloud storage one
zettabyte is equal to trillion gigabytes
now imagine the amount of data the world
generates and how it is being managed so
Cloud experts are responsible for this
smooth transition Google workspace has
already surpassed the mark of 2 billion
users in 2020 and 60 of the total
corporate data is already present in the
cloud so these stats are enough to let
anyone know where this technology is
headed and what wonders are awaiting in
cloud computing Tech giants like Google
Amazon and Microsoft are trying to
conquer this exponentially growing
Market with their products like Amazon
web services Google Cloud platform and
Microsoft Azure furthermore in this fast
paced World a job in this field is more
than worth it the salary is offered in
this field are very lucrative and
fascinating among all the job roles
currently available in cloud computing a
cloud architect in India earns an
average salary of 20 lakhs per annum and
in the United States it goes around 125
000 so these figures are stated by
glassdoor.com and show how beneficial it
is to back a job in this sector today
but the fact is nothing comes easy so we
at simply learn will save some of your
time and let you know about the process
of how to become a cloud expert in 2023
we'll take you through the complete
cloud computing roadmap but before we
begin if you enjoy watching these videos
and find them interesting please
subscribe subscribe to our Channel
because we bring the best videos where
you did also hit the Bell icon to get
notified whenever we drop a new video so
without any further delay let's go
through the agenda for today's video
this video will provide all the Vital
Information about cloud computing
we'll start this video with an
introduction to cloud computing
following that we'll take you through
the skills to become a successful Cloud
expert we'll then take you through the
steps you can take to become a cloud
engineer and finally we'll explore some
of the potential roles and growth
opportunities in the field of cloud
computing so let's start this video with
what is cloud computing cloud computing
in simple terms refers to the practice
of using remote servers on the internet
to store manage and process data instead
of relying on your local computer it
allows you to access your files
applications and services from anywhere
within active internet connection
providing convenience scalability and
flexibility for individuals and
businesses alike
a number of skills are required to
become a master in the field of cloud
computing the first one is technical
skills
Cloud Engineers should have a strong
foundation in areas such as networking
operating systems and programming
languages they should be familiar with
Cloud platforms like Amazon web services
Microsoft Azure or Google Cloud platform
problem solving abilities Cloud
Engineers often encounter complex
technical challenges developing strong
problem solving and troubleshooting
skills is crucial to identify and
resolve issues efficiently
security and compliance knowledge Cloud
Engineers must understand security
practices data privacy regulations and
compliance standards they need to
protect sensitive data and maintain
compliance with industry regulations
continuous learning cloud technology
evolves rapidly so it's essential for
cloud Engineers to have a thirst for
learning keeping up with the latest
trends attending training programs and
obtaining relevant certifications will
help you stay ahead now that we have a
grasp of the skills required let's
discuss the steps you can take to become
a cloud engineer get familiar with Cloud
Concepts start by gaining a basic
understanding of cloud computing
Concepts familiarize yourself with the
advantages different service models such
as infrastructure as a service platform
as a service and software as a service
and deployment models like public
private and hybrid
second is learn Cloud platforms and
Technologies choose a cloud platform to
specialize in such as AWS Azure or gcp
explore their documentation online
tutorials and resources to understand
their offerings services and tools gain
hands-on experience by experimenting
with the platforms and building simple
projects acquiring relevant
certifications Cloud certifications
validate your skills and demonstrate
your expertise to potential employers
consider pursuing certifications such as
AWS certified Cloud practitioner Azure
fundamentals or Google Cloud certified
associate Cloud engineer these
certifications provide a solid
foundation and enhance your credibility
and simply learn has got your back as
always the postgraduate program in cloud
computing designed in collaboration with
Caltech ctme helps you become an Azure
AWS and gcp expert at once this in-depth
cloud computing certification course
lets you master key architectural
principles and develop the skills needed
to become a complete Cloud expert
benefits of this postgraduate program
include Caltech ctme post graduate
certificate enrollment in simple learns
job assist you will receive up to 30
CEUs from Caltech ctme
simply learns job assist help you get
noticed by top hiring companies you can
also attend master classes from Caltech
ctme instructors and live virtual
classes led by industry experts you will
also get Hands-On projects and
integrated Labs there are many more
other features of this postgraduate
program so you can also fast track your
career with this cloud computing
certification and its in-depth course
curriculum which covers the key concept
of azure AWS and gcp platforms and
services such as AWS Lambda Amazon S3
Azure app services and many more so this
program also covers the essential skills
to become an expert in cloud computing
and you can consider this program
because it provides you with a
certification from Caltech ctm a
well-reputed university in the United
States so what are you thinking you can
find the link mentioned in the
description box below the next step is
gain practical experience practical XP
is crucial in the field of cloud
engineering look for opportunities to
work on real world projects through
internships freelance work or personal
projects this hands-on experience will
help you apply your knowledge and
develop problem solving skills the last
step to become a cloud expert is
networking and collaboration connect
with Professionals in the cloud
computing industry through networking
events online forums and social media
platforms engage in discussions ask
questions and learn from their
experiences building a solid
Professional Network can open doors to
new opportunities as a cloud engineer
you'll have diverse career opportunity
let's explore some of the potential
rules and growth paths in cloud
computing Cloud administrator Cloud
experts or administrators oversee and
manage a company's Cloud infrastructure
including policies security protocols
uptime monitoring and technology updates
Cloud infrastructure engineer
this role focuses on designing and
managing the underlying infrastructure
of cloud platforms ensuring scalability
security and performance Cloud Solutions
architect Cloud Solutions architect
design and Implement cloud-based
solutions for organizations they analyze
business requirements and develop
architectural designs to meet specific
needs Cloud security engineer Cloud
security engineer specializes in
securing cloud infrastructures and
services they Implement robbers security
measures monitor for vulnerabilities and
respond to security incidents the
salaries in any of these fields are
lucrative and fascinating
congratulations you have now learned the
steps to become a cloud expert remember
it's a dynamic field that requires
continuous learning and adaptation so
start your journey by building a solid
foundation acquiring relevant
certifications gaining practical
experience and networking with
professionals with dedication and
preservance you can embark on an
exciting and rewarding career in cloud
computing so let's take a minute to hear
from our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers hi I am
Ravine Kumar Jala I live in Mumbai and I
am the co-founder and chief digital and
Technology officer of vcns global I
wanted to cater to customer who wanted
to take the journey towards the cloud so
I decided to opt for the post-graduation
program in cloud computing in
association with Caltech from Simply
learn so I was learning every day and
implementing my learning at my business
to in real time after I come did the
course I was able to structure the whole
Cloud consultancy vertical for my
company we have added seven Cloud
consultancy customers in business time
is money so make a wise investment today
well that's a wrap on this cloud
computing roadmap we hope you found this
video informative and helpful you should
Now understand how to make a career in
this exceptionally growing field
so if you're interested in learning more
about different Technologies there are
plenty of resources available at simply
loan you can also check out our website
for more information on different
certifications so thank you for watching
and we'll see you next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here